the delorean is back with an 88 unit
alpha 5 ev concept people who couldn't
tell a corvette from a civic can
typically immediately spot a delorean
workers in northern ireland produced
just short of 9000 of the v6 powered
stainless steel shelled rear engine
coupes from 1980 to 1982 before delorean
motor company or dmc collapsed under
debt and alleged drug dealing by its
desperate namesake john delorean who was
found not guilty of the charges against
him in 1984 but by then delorean was
done
not many cars have the emotional pull of
a delorean the future is so bright 1980s
automotive icon that was cemented into
pop culture like few other cars after a
star turn as a rolling time machine in
the 1985 mega hit movie back to the
future and the sudden and swift demise
of the company and the man who created
it now 40 years on it appears to be back
john delorean passed away in 2005 at the
age of 80. but 10 years before his death
the remains of the company were bought
up by an irishman who had grand designs
on resurrecting the cars in their
original form but it was not to be now
the brand has moved to the us under the
supervision of yoast devries formerly of
tesla and fisker karma and he's got
plans not just to revive the hallowed
name and the signature car but to expand
and grow delorean into a contender in
both the ev and gas-powered market
segments
first up will be the new delorean known
as the alpha 5 which will be a limited
production high performance all-electric
four-seat sports coupe much like the
original save the electric part the car
was recently announced and renters
revealed delorean says a physical
specimen will debut in august at pebble
beach with production slated for 2024.
devries told autocar that he hopes to
take delorean public at about the same
time the first car gets shown later this
year
only 88 initial ev units are planned you
likely know why that number is key if
you saw the movie in back to the future
the flux capacitor-powered delorean has
to hit 88 miles per hour before it can
launch into time travel mode the noon
delorean ev is designed by georgeto
dujaro who also came up with the
original dmc-12 as the 1980s car was
officially known giugiaro is now the
head of design firm ital design the evs
will be built in italy according to ceo
devries with some powertrain input from
companies in the uk
oddly the first 88 cars will be tied to
nfts in some form and will not be street
legal despite performance numbers that
will include a 150 mile per hour top
speed zero to 60 in under 3.5 seconds
and over 300 miles of range from a 100
kilowatt battery pack
cars built after the initial 88 units
will be street legal if funding and
construction plans reach fruition the ev
will be followed by several other
delorean models including a v8 powered
sports car and a hydrogen-powered suv
among others
but for now the upcoming delorean ev is
looking to the future while paying
homage to the past gull wing doors rear
louvers and the iconic metallic finish
there's no word yet on if it will
include a flux capacitor
you